well some 20 years ago or so but on the
air about 25 years so it might even be
25 years ago I had gone through the
process of coaching and counseling
people getting out of debt on a
one-on-one basis I was just starting on
the radio quarter of a century ago and
even though I'm a big-time math nerd I
had discovered that debt what Larry
Burkett used to say is not the problem
it is the symptom of the problem the
problem is the behaviors disorganized
you buy crap you can't afford money you
don't have to impress people you don't
really like debt is not the problem it's
the symptom of the person in your mirror
person in my mirror I can get the guy in
my mirror to behave he can be skinny and
rich but he's got issues and that's what
we've learned a long long time ago and
so I quit using only math to do personal
finance because personal finance is more
about behavior than it is about math
math is not the problem an example is
you know what you pay in commissions on
your investments is not the problem the
fact that you put nothing into your
investments is the problem as a matter
of fact there's a key piece of research
from the investment world that shows
that 74% of the reason people have
successful retirement plans is what's
called savings rate meaning they
actually put money into savings it's not
the rate of return and it's not the
expenses and it's not the type of
investment and it's not how complicated
it is
it's just that they put money in there I
met with an NFL player stop by my office
meeting with one of my guys about three
or four weeks ago he stopped by here and
he had a million six in cash in the bank
making 1% and he was ashamed I said why
are you ashamed well it doesn't feel
sophisticated will dude it's a whole
heck of a lot more sophisticated than
those people that don't have a million
six in the bank because they started
doing a bunch of quote sophisticated
stuff and they were more concerned about
their sophistication than they were
actually doing it doing it is what
matters this all this theory financial
people are the world's worst about a
bunch of dadgum theories it's this
theory it's that theory and they think
this stuff is all somehow done in a
vacuum it's not done in a vacuum it's
done in the middle of the transmission
going out and your daughter needing a
prom dress life is messy baby and it's
called personal finance so we started
teaching people to get away the best way
to get out of debt is to get some quick
wins the best way you get a quick win is
you list your debts not highest interest
rate the smallest to attack them you
list them smallest debt to largest
because when you pay off a little when
you have an old boy moment and then you
pay off another one you have oh yeah a
moment and then you have a yeah baby
moment as you go along you get more
excited and you get more intense and you
get more focused and we call that the
debt snowball 25 years ago now there are
entire websites devoted to how stupid
Dave Ramsey is because he can't do math
but I've gotten more people out of debt
than any 73 of those idiots put together
so now now we know it's okay though
because it has just come out the Harvard
Business Review our research suggests
that people are more motivated to get
out of debt not only by concentrating on
one account but also by beginning with
the smallest twenty-five years and five
million people been through Financial
Peace University 13 million people
listen to this show ten and a half
million people have bought our books and
Harvard Business Review has discovered
that our research suggests that people
are more motivated to get out of debt
not only by concentrating on one account
but by also beginning with the smallest
we found that consumers have
concentrated their repayments on one of
their several accounts paid down more of
the credit card debt than those who
dispersed the repayments equally across
multiple accounts with evidence that
repayment strategy influences debt
repaid
the mounts we conducted three
experiments to investigate the
psychological mechanisms underlying
these results see I knew it is just but
I you know I just I I graduated from
college and state schools so University
of Tennessee's just didn't make you
smart enough bill do this oh I'm so glad
Harvard Business Review come along and
figure this crap out for us because we
just didn't know it already participants
who had been assigned to a more
concentrated strategy paying off one or
just a few accounts at a time did indeed
perceive greater progress toward their
goal of getting out of debt which turn
in turn enhanced their motivation to
succeed just could to say it that
beautifully I just said people get fired
up when they pay off debt and they keep
going that's what I said I'm from
Tennessee though focusing on paying down
the account with a lot of smallest
balance tends to have the most powerful
effect on people's sense of progress you
know why because they have crap you guys
are freaking geniuses up read Harvard
man so glad you guys figured this out
because none of the rest of us knew what
was going on and and I'll just the next
time one of these people that you know
it's 28 years old lives and their
mother's basement writes a blog about
how stupid Dave Ramsey is I'll just send
them the Harvard Business Review and I'm
sure that will settle the debate
personal finance folks is 80% behavior
it's only 20% head knowledge you want to
know what's wrong with your money you
you're the problem
Islip bad news great news is you're the
solution and you don't live in Russia
you live in the United States of America
where you get to choose to change right
now you ready change ready set go tada
you're different just because you
decided to be it's magical so amazing
you
is get to decide I was stupid yesterday
today I'm not stupid anymore
you can just decide not to do stupid
anymore all my parents were stupid I
don't care about your parents I'm
talking about you I you know it you get
to decide and you don't have to have a
master's degree in finance to figure
this crap out and you don't even have to
attended a patent in Harvard Business
School you just have to live on less
than you make a concept Congress can't
grasp and you can decide to do that
ready set go
you're now cooking at home and you're
needy not eating out ready set go
you start buying term insurance into the
whole life and getting ripped off ready
set go
you don't fleece your cars you buy used
cars and you pay cash ready set go you
go to every dollar calm and you get on a
budget and you agree on your spending
with your spouse ready set go
you save an emergency fund ready set go
you can do this and regular people do it
every day long before Harvard Business
Review had a clue we were all out here
as a matter of fact they still don't
know we're here Shh
don't tell them this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
down
[Music]